the moment that i decided to go to the
unknown
without money in a foreign country when
there is
no smartphones you need to find an
internet cafe just to communicate with
the world
but you are supported by the community
of gated great israelis which is
which was awesome i never felt scared or
alone
at any point welcome to 20-minute
leaders
just sit back relax and learn from the
leaders of today
it's a journey each one is different
unique inspiring
let's get started
[Music]
this episode is powered by jventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley
in partnership with lomi tech and
sponsored by hippo insurance
touring opposed labs and hillel at
stanford
if you love hearing crazy
entrepreneurial stories then get ready
for this one
meet gilad shamri the founder and ceo of
growth
artists gilad is a serial entrepreneur
and the ceo of growth artists consulting
agency based in san francisco
by the time gillard was 13 he already
established two businesses
and at the age of 25 he managed to sell
his first company
now with over 12 years of experience in
helping startups in silicon valley find
product market fit
he is writing a book about how to adopt
his methodology to any type of business
and
every aspect of life gilad xiaomi thank
you for joining me all the way from
silicon valley to my couch in tel aviv
how are you today
i'm great thank you it's sunday here and
the sun is shining in san francisco when
the sun is shining san francisco we
always
need to be thankful i i love that
i love that perspective gilad a y
combinator startup
a consultant um you know guest lecturer
in many
um institutions co-founder of your own
initiatives
vp growth at the start that was acquired
by wix and
many more positions in many more areas
previously in the israeli air force
an interesting childhood to begin with
and all around
one of the most interdisciplinary
leaders that i've had on this show in
over 400 episodes which
you know when we when we started this i
asked you gilad what what are we going
to talk about
because honestly you know there's not
enough time to fit everything that i
want to talk about
and so i think the best way if you'll
indulge in this is to
let's just go back to the beginning talk
about you know your origins
who you are and then we'll touch on a
few fun things but let's start from
there
okay first of all thank you very much
for having me giving this
opportunity to share my experience
and so yeah um i'm originally from
the periphery of israel from a small
desert town called
where i grew up most of my childhood but
not all of it
and grew up with a single mother with a
teacher
and and just raised me
by her own and because we didn't have a
lot of resources
i and didn't get any pocket money on
their
regular basis like most of the children
in my uh in my school
i had to find um ways in order
to feel like everybody else and
um there's not much happening in iraq
but
if there's one thing that aladdin is
known for is the
amazing music festival that was
happening in the 90s
on a yearly basis that actually stopped
because of a
horrifying um
incident um but until then
that was what arad was known for and
as uh and seven years old i was when we
moved to a lot from jerusalem
and i i recognized the business
opportunity i was walking down the
streets and i saw all these kiosks
selling all these goods
and i thought what what how can i
leverage it into
into making uh into money so and
basically all i wanted to do with this
money is to like hogging i don't even
remember this the pogs
everybody had it i i i didn't
and i really wanted to be like anyone
else i have something to trade and talk
about
besides a hide and seek at school and um
so i saw this cup popcorn
kiosk and then i one day i returned home
and i asked my mom for
uh for money to buy uh groceries to make
popcorn
she taught me how to to make this
popcorn i created it uh
we cooked it together for the first time
and then we bagged that she made like a
really nice
carton board with my name on it gilad's
popcorn and then i just
uh and just went to the the streets
and sold the popcorn and in two hours i
was out of popcorn
i got so excited i went back and created
another batch
i did that and in the next year
i already had like multiple uh
friends three of my friends who carried
my brand name
and sold this popcorn and but i
made less money and then i had because i
i
i didn't it was the first time i really
hit like business when i'm like
oh okay so if we're selling two shekels
for one popcorn
i cannot give two shekels for my friends
to sell it because i'm not making any
profit
and that was my first like business
lesson and um
and then we did i did that every year
until the uh
festival was closed and then it was my
bar mitzvah
and i got uh with my money that i got
from the berezva
i it was 1997 and
i bought with all the money from
bermitzva a cd burner
an hp 7200 with an external lpt
connection
and at a time when a blank cd rom
tdk city rom costs 25 shekels this is
and this is nice it's a lot of money
and i started um basically
i was the only person in iraq who had a
city burner i think except for like the
industrial places
and i just started selling uh games
pirate games in school and
i think i was the richest kid in my
school
and when we moved to the from
esod to
yeah my mom was already talking about
that we're going to leave a lot
to some matula in the north and
i had to maximize uh this time in order
to make as much money
so what do one do he joined the school's
newspaper as an editor and there i was
uh creating content this is the first
time i
introduced my like the my content uh
content strategy and i the first draft
that i gave
was basically a price list of how much
in which games
we have and how much it's going to cost
you to get them where you can find me
after school
and then the editor was like no no no no
no this is
the this is not what it's for you said
that you're gonna come
and write about games and pc
and and and and i'm like okay
so then i created this content about
uh this horrifying quest game conference
magoya which was like
really like not for our age to play if
you remember
it it is what one of these games that we
were like walking a video in a horror
movie
and within this content
i put in some i i i
implemented some some stuff that's
associated with
selling other games that are in stock
right now of course
and uh and and and then i uh and i
scaled
um and we and we left a lot and
everybody got after 9.98 everybody got a
external uh city burner already and um
and the business was not interesting
anymore and
um and then you know i did every other i
think israeli
uh israeli route at that point i did the
other three years in the army in the air
force the
and then after that a i lived in tel
aviv
for about a year
and i went to so i i did like a lot
in london and then i went to uh south
america i traveled for eight months
and um and that was the first time that
i took a very
bad tip and this is one of those
this i think this is across this
something that i always go back to
uh that i'm thinking okay
there's you get a lot of crosswords in
your life and there's
this one tipping point to where you
could have taken
advice from somebody it will completely
change your life
and where there's for the best for the
worst is just a matter of perspective
and at that point i was
saving i was making like i think i had
like twelve thousand dollars
that i was supposed to go with to south
america to travel for eight months
and one of the ways that you can do
that is except definitely not take all
this cash with you but
going into uh depositing into the bank
account and then paying all these extras
from from it
was in london so it's per pound a dollar
a dollar to peso and then which meso
according to the country you are
and somebody gave me an advice that i
should just buy
traveler checks traveler checks i know
if you're familiar with it's not very
popular these days but you you you
exchange this
12 000 into checks that you can only
cash out and if they're getting lost you
can basically
um call and they'll provide you new ones
because they're
secured and i travel i bought the twelve
thousand dollars to travel their checks
started my my trip in argentina in
buenos aires going to down to towards
antarctica and shawaya and going up
towards colombia
and that was the plan at least and then
after three weeks i was
uh took to the hostel in a
place called rio gallegos i got back to
my room
after cashing 500 of traveler checks and
i saw
that all my traveler checks was stolen
now at first
i didn't panic because i said okay i
just got together it's secured
little did i know that american express
who provided these checks would do
anything they can to prevent me from
getting these checks back
it was always under investigation for
months
and my mom which is a very supportive
person send me her money
to her a little bit she had like so i
can continue traveling because we all
knew that they're gonna get this money
back and i'm gonna pay her back
but at some point i realized that
they're just not gonna
send me back the money and it was either
going back to israel and finished this
trip after two months
or just going to the unknown
right and michael this is one of these
experiences you asked me earlier what
will be this
one couple of experiences that you think
that really changed your life and
created you who you are
this is exactly it the moment
that i decided to go to the unknown
without money
in a foreign country when there is no
smartphones
you need to find an internet cafe just
to communicate with the world
but you are supported by the community
of gated great israelis which is
which was awesome i never felt scared or
alone
at any point uh as you know 75
of the backpackers in south america are
israelis
so you you it's like a very long
actual statistic and
um that's what somebody said once and
actually when you were
there you'll feel like it's more like
ninety percent actually right places
where
sorel is bouncing and
uh so i kept traveling and i
i found my ways uh to
creating creating like creating capital
so i can continue traveling
and uh all legal just let's go there
and um and
at some point i got to i got to colombia
and it was with the la my last pennies
and then i realized that um it's either
going back to israel or
really can continue traveling with with
with with nothing
right and um unfortunately
the universe came to hell like
was there to help me and i
found myself uh by the way i'm five
six i'm not a tall guy but uh you can't
be out my look just gave it away
my looks were i i guess uh
somebody find interesting my looks there
and i found myself modeling in colombia
for like three weeks
doing doing 100 a day
and continue traveling and when i back
back to israel
i um i
i was i think when you're 21 you have
this experience like
you actually managed to get to the
bottom
and got yourself out of there so
the amount of trust that you have in the
universe especially as an entrepreneur
is something that is absolutely
priceless you can do anything and this
is
and this is the this is the thing that i
was carrying with me and
and continued traveling i lived in
barcelona and in denmark
and and it was the first time that i
went to san francisco
and uh founded my first startup and tspa
which was acquired by a competitor it's
a marketplace for
salespeople and then i
after that experience i really wanted to
do something um
impactful that is not necessarily money
oriented
and by the way looking back
at you know what what you're doing what
you've done in the past
you know few years and you know hearing
your journey and hearing your childhood
and all these experiences it makes
perfect sense to me why
why you founded you know the
organizations that you did and why you
founded
you know growth artists and lecturing
and growthx academy
and in the idc and and in consulting the
startups because and i think
you know a lot of it goes back to those
even those childhood experiences of
selling
popcorn and and you know marketing your
city burner
business in high school or agalot or
you know getting through tough times
while traveling
just to get up to i just want to say
that for you know from an outsider's
perspective
hearing about this journey makes a lot
of sense
why you're passionate about the things
you're passionate about
indeed yeah yeah i think it's
uh going back to
no i'm just saying like to summarize
that going back into
experiences in life that you in
retrospective asking yourself should
have
taken this advice or not taking this
advice
probably this bad advice that i took
into getting
to south america with travelers checks
compared to just a credit card
is something that i would not have this
experience without it
because i was just having a great eight
months of travel with my
israeli bodies and i would have like the
great experiences
but not likely that i will push myself
into the situations where i need to
create gold out of sand
that makes a lot of sense growth artists
marketing growth working with startups
bring me to today so until now we talked
about you know your history your
upbringing
today gilad you starters come to you for
advice you're working with marketers and
and growth people
you know from all walks of life why
you know what what gets you so excited
about growth marketing content
and then how does that translate into
your day-to-day today
great question so um first of all i'm
i'm in san francisco and uh you
you're from palo alto so you know that
the uh the difference between the
the entrepreneurs that come to and
usually live in san francisco
compared to the triple actually lulu's
palo alto in in
silicon valley is that san francisco
attracts the
mainly the early stage startup
founders and um my specialty is
marketplaces
because most of my experience is
building marketplaces
and when people come to me
is because i i provide a different
perspective that is not necessarily
technical
oriented solution but another way
of looking and how to navigating your
startup
in order instead and i'll put in the
brutal truth
is that especially with first-time
entrepreneurs
when i'm trying to implement is to get
them understand
that they're not likely to
succeed and generate growth with their
first
idea or product but as you know
investors invest in a team because they
know
that they're more likely to pivot their
idea and their
product as long as the team is strong
and they're capable to maneuver fast and
sp this is all about speed so the brutal
truth of how i communicate it to
entrepreneurs
is that it's a very
entrepreneurship is a very expensive
sport and in order to succeed in it
you need to have be in shape and you
need to have
adopt a methodology that will help you
to
kill your startups fast not to succeed
get your idea break it down to
assumptions
experiments prioritize it
and kill it fast look for the
things around you to prove that your
idea
suck yes is the change in the
methodology that entrepreneurs need to
start to understanding you're because
you're getting into that
most of them are saw a lot of tv shows
like from shark tank to the um suddenly
on this idea that you're having this
what's the problem
let's just get this idea we're gonna be
all millionaires and we love this
enthusiasm this is part of it you cannot
do a startup without it
but it's a it's a roller coaster and
uh you need to be mentally strong and to
understand that this is
a very long this is not a marathon it's
you need to act like a marathon because
you need to be fast but this is a very
long journey and it doesn't really
matter
well there nobody cares about whether
you you succeeded in your first
startup or your second startup the the
the thing that the most important is
that when you're having a good
methodology
and good guidance you'll be able
to learn from mistakes
and experiments that you ran deeply
in order not to go back to the same
thing
so and this is what i'm trying to
communicate in in
in the book that i'm writing right now
called growth artists
and uh and to really
try to get this methodology out there
and mainly in the way that people see
the progress of their startup
right glad i can't 20 minutes always go
by way way too fast there's
you know 10 more things that i we didn't
even begin talking about
and that that i would love to pick your
brain on but i think we'll have to leave
that for another episode but in the
meantime
i want to thank you for being both so
generous for your time here
but also for being vulnerable and and
sharing with me you know
things all the way back from the
childhood that you know might
not appear you know in in other places
or on the headlines of tech crucial
farmers but really they are
they are what makes up the identity and
and i think that you're absolutely right
when i think
back to you know why i do the things
that i do or the things that i care
about
i think back to you know eight years old
and this and something that happened to
me
you know on my own you know post army
trip
and and those are the things that they
make up us as entrepreneurs
so gilad thank you very very much i have
one last question the most important one
uh which is three words that you would
use to describe yourself
and i apologize they didn't prepare you
enough for this but whatever it is i'll
take it
wow i hope that you have beeps in the uh
in the
in this recording but i would say a
stubborn [__]
[Laughter]
you didn't give me a chance to say that
we don't have much budget so there's no
beefs here
but i'll take it as it is
thank you very very much i'll see you
for that beer in san francisco that we
talked about
and until then stay safe and stay
healthy
thank you very much for the opportunity
have a great day
thank you